Lindsay Lohan got her groove back Selena
Gomez is cutting a man out of her life
plus beating we're tossing one back for
the Queen today it is a holy day on the
daily Denny today because it is
Beyonce's birthday royal highness turns
37 but if you know anything you know
every day is v-day but we're still gonna
turn up for her special day we've got a
special Beyonce themed cocktail waiting
for you at the end of this video
but speaking of turning up I'm not sure
anyone had a better Labor Day weekend
than Lindsay Lohan after she was caught
getting her life in Mykonos Greece
[Music]
guys this video Lindsey dancing and
Mykonos Greece went viral and now this
is my forever mood meeting us by the
ways where Lindsey has set up shop these
days with her Lohan beach house Mykonos
hotspot which is also the center of her
upcoming MTV reality show now as the
clip of lilo made the rounds everybody
got in on the action trying to recreate
her lose you know lift yourself
encourage everyone to hashtag do the
lilo now the onlooker responsible for
this gem is Neil weighing in et FaceTime
him today to find out how lilo got her
groove back Lindsey hadn't showed up at
a time so we're just chilling at the bar
and then there were a lot of cameras
were laying people were just doing
different things and then they were
being filmed and there Lindsey doesn't
show up and then she brought her three
outfits and then she at first were just
filling her tent and there were
bodyguard
bodyguards so we were not able to take
any photos and then she decided to get
on stage and then she like played music
on the DJ's computer she interacted with
the DJ she actually with the crowd
downstairs everybody was crazy she was
having the best time of her life and
then that's when I decided I have to
talk him in this moment because it's
legendary all I can say is I'm ready for
the Lindsay Lohan Renaissance you guys
The Parent Trap handshake Mean Girls
Jingle Bell Rock and now Mykonos Lohan
dance she's back right now on to another
artist entering back into the cultural
zeitgeist Selena Gomez she recently took
a bit of a step back from the spotlight
to focus on herself for businesses and
her next album and now she is Elle
magazine's October cover girl apparently
the interview happened just six days
after news broke of Demi Lovato's
overdosed else as Selena was visibly
choked up when speaking about her friend
Selena said quote all I'm saying is I
reached out to her personally I didn't
do a public thing I didn't want to I I
loved her
I've known her since I was 7 so it's
that's what I'll say but that's not the
only thing Selena is breaking her
silence on she tells the Magma's she
feels very sure of herself right now and
doesn't feel emotionally unstable the
senior even played a few songs off her
new album for Elle contributor Mickey
rap game
he says the first song she plays for him
is about cutting a man out of her life
after 1,460 days fans are speculating
it's about Justin Bieber who of course
is now engaged thinking Lee Baldwin the
lyrics read without you I don't
overthink it I'm drunk and I might as
well tell you get you out of my head now
well guys the Biebs speculation didn't
exactly sit well with Selena who took to
Instagram to voice her truth
she said she's bombed by the article but
rarely surprised and she told fans y'all
know me and my heart I can't help it so
I'll post some of my photos from the
Coache collection and work with a21 my
heart and maybe edit my actual lyrics as
you will all hear it soon and we can't
wait for this new music apparently
there's a song on the album called
flawless which she describes as a song
she'll sing for the rest of her life but
you know what she better get in line
because I'm still singing Beyonce's
flawless I woke up like this and it's
promised we are celebrating Beyonce's
birthday today with a cocktail recipe
fit for queen bee and her hive our
resident lifestyle expert Holly Stevens
whipped up the drink for us and is
showing you how to make it at home
[Music]
first up the Beehive I knew that I
wanted to make a drink with lemonade
because let's be real
was anything ever more epic than
Beyonce's visual album ya know since
Beyonce is lovingly called queen bee by
her loyal fans I decided to sweeten the
lemonade with honey instead of sugar to
get started you're gonna need 6 lemons
1/2 a cup of honey 11 cups of water
crushed ice whiskey and some fresh mint
and lemons for garnish so you're going
to squeeze 1 cup of juice from the
lemons into the pitcher so then you guys
are gonna take a half a cup of honey and
you're gonna add it into your picture
whoo that is so pretty
be careful with your honey then you guys
are gonna take 11 cups of water we're
basically just making our lemonade so
you're gonna go ahead and you're gonna
pour them in the pitcher and then stir
it up it's 1 & 2 we're getting close to
the top
protip play Beyonce's Greatest Hits
turned all the way up and stir on the
beat
please on the beat and the beat so you
can go ahead and put the lemonade in the
fridge and serve it chilled as is sans
alcohol or you can turn things up with a
little liquor
honey and whiskey go together alike
Beyonce and jay-z or Beyonce and
windblown hair you get the point
it's legendary okay so now you're gonna
grab your preferred brand of whiskey and
you're gonna add one to two ounces to
each glass depending on how festive
you're feeling okay so then fill the
rest of your glass with ice and a
lemonade then you guys are gonna make
this so pretty and garnish with fresh
mint and a slice of lemon all right
raise your glass and toast to Sasha
Fierce but whatever you do don't spill
don't worry how I never drop the alcohol
actually that's a lie I'm a great a
clumsy clumsy
anyway Hallie is showing you how to make
another Beyonce themed cocktail today
and that's up for you guys now all right
happy birthday B cheers to you Queen we
don't deserve you